- We've got to see ourself
the way we want to be
and then we have to live with it.
People should say you should slow down
that's a bunch of crap,
we should speed up.
When we get into the success zone
everything that our life starts to change.
You only have to know two things.
You have to know where you're going
and you have to know that
you're going to get there.
- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs solve all
of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn the
law of attraction master
Bob Proctor and his top
ten rules to success
Volume two.
Rule number, three is my
personal favorite and I'd love
to know which ones you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
for folks or others who can be inspired
and you can also win a prize, as well.
And also when you write
it it's much more likely
to stick for yourself, as well.
Enjoy.
(airplane flying)
(basketball bounce)
(pop music)
- See people don't resist change
people resist being changed.
Mmm yes we've got to change ourself
we've got to build a new image
a picture in our mind.
We've got to see yourself
the way we want to be
and then we have to live with it.
That's, you go to the gym
work out that's what you do.
You build a picture how you want to see
this arm, this arm and
you build that picture
and then you build the body.
While you build the life in your mind
take your pen and write
out how you want to live
and always start by writing
I'm so happy and grateful
now that.
And the second you write it
you've got it intellectually.
The moment you impress it upon your
emotional mind you've got it emotionally.
And it's only a period of time till it
manifests on the physical plane.
Yes spirit works from a
higher to a lower potential.
Let that little yellow dot on the screen
represent your level of awareness.
This represents your level of awareness.
This is what you're aware of.
Now everything you've got in your life
everything, your
relationships, your money,
everything is an expression of your own
level of awareness.
See people that earn 50,000
a year are not very good
because they want 50.
People are earning 50
because they're not aware
of how to earn 150.
People that are suffering from headaches
they're not suffering headaches
because they want to
suffer from headaches.
They're suffering from headaches
because they're not aware of
how to eliminate the headache.
It's their head, they made it
ache, they can make it stop.
So you see it's awareness we're after.
Now think of this.
If that little dot
represents our awareness
and it's responsible for
everything we've got in life
just think of how your life could change
if we magnify it just a little bit.
I mean everything would start to change.
Our relationships would change.
We would be healthier, we
would live in healthier bodies.
We would know more people,
we'd earn more money.
We'd be able to do more
interesting things.
And if we just increased
it a little bit more
everything starts to shift.
Well I've been living
this way now for 40 years
it absolutely fascinating.
I celebrated my 70th birthday last week
I got more energy than most people 20.
I have absolutely no
intentions of slowing down.
People should say you should slow down
that's a bunch of crap,
we should speed up.
wWe've got more power yet you know
the most erudite scientist alive
can't even guess what you
and I are capable of doing.
No one knows what we're capable of.
All the powers are in the present
that's within you and within me.
Slow down, we're just starting to warm up.
What we want to do is calm down.
You can go at warp speed
and stay very healthy
if you stay relaxed.
And that's really the secret.
Now just imagine we expand
our awareness a little more.
Do you know what this program
is doing for you today?
It's expanding your awareness,
that's what the program is all about.
Every time you come every time you come
to one of these programs
your awareness is widened.
Your world starts to change.
You think oh yeah, that's
pretty interesting.
And it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger.
Our awareness keeps changing.
You know that no one knows how much money
you're capable of earning.
There's no one can even guess at
what you're capable of earning.
We want to become aware
aware like we are because
we're not aware of
how to do it better.
We know how to do it better.
Every person in this
room intellectually knows
how to do a better job then they're doing.
Everyone in the room
knows how to earn more
than they're earning.
But they're not doing it.
You see having the
knowledge is not the deal.
having the knowledge I mean
I remember when I was a kid.
Schoolteacher would say to
me, "Bob why'd you do that?"
I'd say, "I don't know?"
"What do you mean you don't know?
"You know better."
"I know I did it, I don't know"
I was in the Navy every
commanding officer,
"Proctor why did you do that?"
"I don't know sir."
"What do you mean you don't know?
"You know better."
"I know"
"Why'd you do it?"
"I don't know."
(laughing)
You see I didn't know
why I was doing things.
Do you know that we do things
that we don't want to do?
It gives us results we don't want to get.
Yet we do them anyway.
Do you know what addiction is?
It's never getting enough
of what you don't want.
Getting a lot of people addicted
to results that they don't want.
Why do we keep doing it?
You see I think when we start to see that
that's when we start to become aware
of how to take control over our life.
And that's really what we want to do.
So you see awareness is the big deal.
We want to become aware of
the obvious opportunities
that are available to us.
We are surrounded by opportunity.
They're everywhere you go.
There is an abundance, there's
no shortage of opportunity.
We can win, and we can win in a big way.
Now when we lack awareness
we miss the opportunity.
I used to always say
that you know the trick
is to be in the right
place at the right time.
I've been in the right
place at the right time
many times in my life, but I blew it.
You know why?
I wasn't aware that I
was in the right place
at the right, I had to look back at it.
Think of it there's something else,
it's being aware that you're
in the right place at the right
time's not good enough.
You've got to be aware that
you're in the right place
at the right time.
Habits.
Good habits will give
you results that stick.
Bad habits will destroy everything I have.
Some bad habits.
That's right, all my habits are not great.
So if you've got some bad
habits, don't feel bad.
So does your next-door neighbor.
So does your mentor, or your coach.
So does your mother and
father, if they're alive.
So does everyone.
And the trick of life is
to replace a bad habit
with a good habit.
I used to hang around bars all the time
and one day I went in I picked up a glass
and I looked around and I thought,
they're all bums in here.
And then it dawned on me I'm always here.
(laughs)
I learned something.
I put the glass down they said
I'm never coming back here
again, and I'm never going to drink this
and I never did.
And it was a long time ago
but you know what I did?
I went from spending
all my money in the bar
to the racetrack and I started to bet
it all on horses.
So I went from making somebody
with a bar get wealthy
and then I started to feed the horses.
And one day I woke up
and I learned something.
If you don't consciously and deliberately
replace a bad habit with a good habit
you will automatically
create another bad habit.
Now what is a habit?
A habit is an idea that has
been planted in the garden
of your subconscious mind
and then repetitively fed
for a sufficient period of time
that you act on it without
giving any thought to it.
I'll give you an example.
I want you to right now mentally imagine
you're pulling on your
underwear in the morning.
What foot you put in first?
I put my right foot it,
if I tried to put my left
foot in my underwear first
I'd stagger and I'd fall over.
You may say, what's this got to do with?
It it's got everything to do with it.
Why do I put my right foot
you may put your left.
Certainly a lot of people do.
Well when I was just a little gaffer
I didn't have a clue of
how to put underwear on
my mother or my grandmother
and my father or somebody
came along and they had the underwear,
"Put your foot in here.
"Your other foot."
What did they do?
They had the underwear prepared
as if they were going to put it on.
And so pretty soon I was doing
it like they were doing it.
They through repetition
planted the idea in my head
in my mind.
Well now think of this
you don't just form habits
of how to get dressed
you form habits to do
everything that you do.
And some of them are not that productive.
Any idea that you keep
dwelling on and impressing
upon your subconscious mind becomes fixed
in the subconscious mind.
A habit is nothing but
an idea that's fixed
in the subconscious mind that you act on
without giving any conscious thought.
Many years ago I went in to train
the Prudential Insurance
Company of America their agents.
I ended up training all of their agents
and I only got them to do two things.
This is in the early 70s.
I got them to form the habit
of being in front of a
prospect before nine AM
and ask everybody they talked to
to purchase $100,000 worth of insurance.
I said, "You don't have to sell them
"just give them the
opportunity to say no."
Do you know the sales
in that company went up
by hundreds of millions of dollars.
I had a retired VP tell me he thought
it was a billion.
Just changing two habits.
What habit you want to change?
I'm forever checking out habits I've got.
I'm in the habit right
now of changing my diet.
And do you know something,
I've been doing it for
going on three weeks it's getting easier
but it's still not that easy.
It's still like telling
children eat some of that
when nobody's looking.
Doesn't work, doesn't work,
I'm looking.
What habit are you going to form and you
shouldn't do it for more than two at once
it'll become too big too
heavy and you won't form any.
Make up your mind you're
going to do it every day,
every day, every day
until you don't have to think about it .
And then you'll automatically do it.
I guarantee you.
This idea will change your life.
Think about it all day
because that is definitely an idea
that will give you
results that will stick.
Right now I'm standing in
the middle of my library.
This is my favorite place.
You know Earl will say
if you surround your mind
with greatness some of
its going to rub up.
Well hopefully some of
it hs rubbed off on me.
I have maybe three or 4,000
books here on the shelf
they're all in alphabetical
order and by author
they're all cataloged so I
know where to find something.
just like that I go by authors more than
the title of the book.
Do you know that when I
started studying these books
I really didn't know
very much about anything
I had two months high school.
I was 26 years old.
I had a bad work record, a bad attitude
and and virtually no experience.
And you know in a relatively
short period of time
my income went from
4,000 to $175,000 a year.
Then it went over a million.
I'm going to share some
information with you that
it could change the direction of your life
like night and day.
And when I say that I want you to really
stop and take a look at your life.
Take an honest look at your life.
I was thinking just before
I start to make this
we have actually been conditioned
to kid with ourselves.
To lie to ourselves.
To not really
take an honest look at
the results we're getting.
I want you to take a real
honest look at your results.
And when you look at them ask yourself,
am I living the way I really want to live?
You see most people aren't.
One of the first questions I ask a person
that comes to work with me I want to know
what's the most they've
ever earned in a year.
Now I really don't care what the answer is
but I want to know what the answer is.
Because you see if
if a person says the most
I've ever earned in years
is $50,000 I know where
their mind is programmed.
If they tell me the most
I've ever earned is $250,000
I know where they're programmed.
And then I want to find
out what they want.
And I know then what has to shift
because their mind is programmed
and if they're really going to live
the way they want to live they
they've got to change the program.
And if they don't change the program
then nothing really happens.
I want to suggest that to
make up your mind you're going
to get in what we call the success zone.
Yet it's a way of thinking, now get this.
If 95, 96 percent of the
population are blowing it
if one percent of the
population are earning about 95%
of all the money you're not going to get
a whole lot of people agree
with what you're doing.
Most people are going to
look at you kind of strange,
what are you going there for?
You went there last month.
What are you listening to that for?
You listened to that before.
What are you reading?
What do you read the same
book over and over for?
They don't understand.
And you see they're
advertising their ignorance
by the questions they ask.
When we get into the success zone
everything in our life starts to change.
But understand this
you're going to be a bit of an oddball.
You're out of the box,
you're not one of the masses.
And when you get out of the box
your whole world starts to shift.
There's a box and there's a leader.
Leader get people excited
about improving the
quality of whatever it is themselves,
their work, whatever they're doing.
People follow leaders
because they want to.
People don't follow leaders
because they have to.
That becomes a form of dictatorship
and that never works.
The great leaders people want to follow.
And leaders inspire you,
leaders pull the very best out of you.
Leaders know how to look inside
and bring the best of you to the surface.
Cause you to look a a higher
side of your own personality.
What the world is always
is looking for its leader.
It's silly, who's going to lead the leader
is going to lead.
(laughs)
And the leader just automatically emerges.
If they threw 50 of us into a committee
and say you don't have to elect a leader
elect one but the leader is going to lead
and that probably isn't
the one that's elected.
- [Man] Yeah so true.
Leader's don't stop they know how to get
the best out of people.
I want to talk to you
about where you're going
and what you want to do with your life.
You see, most people never
go after what they want
because they don't know every step
they have to take to get there.
I want you to think of a person
going up the side of a wall of ice.
Now the only rule for reaching a goal
that you have to know is
knowing where you're going
and knowing that you're
going to get there.
You do not have to know how
you're going to get there.
Now pay attention to this for a moment.
Imagine the climber has all his equipment,
he's got his crampons,
he's got his climbing rope,
his hardware, his ice access.
How does he get to the top?
He's standing on the
ground and he's looking at
maybe a hundred foot vertical wall of ice.
He looks up and he has absolutely no idea
the path that he's going to take.
He just sees himself at the top.
He reaches up and he puts one pick in
and then another pick.
Then he raises one foot
and then the other.
Now he's not standing
on the ground any longer
he's suspended on the wall
on a vertical wall of ice
that goes up 100 feet.
He adapts to the changes that is
taking place in his environment
and then and only then
does he see the next step.
And he moves this pick then this pick,
then this foot then this foot.
Now that's how he gets to the top
a step at a time.
And that's how you're
going to get to your goal.
You just have to know
the first step to take
and when you take that step
you're going to find that your
conditions, your circumstance
and environment will change.
Then you see how you have
to make the next step.
It's a matter of adapting all the time
you only have to know two things.
You have to know where you're going
and you have to know that
you're going to get there.
You've got to see it in your mind.
Now this is the beautiful scenario
this is what it's all about.
Save that in your mind
and think of it often
think every time you think of your goal
and you're trying to figure
out how you're going to do it
think of that vertical wall of ice.
What's the next step?
That's all you really have to know.
One step at a time and you'll
get to wherever you're going.
That's how Hillary got to
the top of Mount Everest.
In Napoleon Hill's book,
Think And Grow Rich
he said now right here we
come to a rather strange fact.
We tend to minimize the things we can do,
the goals we can accomplish.
And for some equally strange reason
we think other people can
accomplish things that we cannot.
And he points out that
there's a difference
between wishing proofing and
being ready to receive them.
So no one's ready for a thing until
they believe that they can acquire it.
The state of mind must be
belief and not mere of a wish.
Yeah he was under consciousness
and said open-mindedness is
essential to belief.
Closed minds will not inspire
faith courage orderly.
- [Narrator] A German engineer
by the name of Karl Benz
had a fantasy
and he literally turned
his fantasy into a fact.
And in January 1886 Karl Benz
was issued a patent for
the Benz motor carriage
and the age of the automobile had done.
This is a replica of
that magnificent machine.
And you know, before Benz
ever turned his fantasy
into a theory, even certainly long before
he turned it into a fact,
he had to ask himself
a couple of questions that you and I
and every other dreamer
will have to go through.
He had to ask himself,
am I able to do this?
Well he seemed to have
that innate awareness
of this higher self this image
of perfection within him.
And he saw himself as a
person that was actually
able to take and turn
the fantasy into effect.
Now, he must have been
a pretty courageous guy
because there were no horseless
carriages in those days.
But then he had to ask
himself, am I willing?
And you see, he'd ask
himself, am I willing
to accept the ridicule
that I'm bound to get?
Am I willing to accept the failures?
Well, he said yes I am willing.
He was willing to pay the ultimate price
to turn his fantasy into a fact.
And ridicule he got,
his own partner thought
he had gone mad.
And he had to find himself
a more congenial colleague
to work with.
He would take this thing
out in the evening,
he'd take it out at night
so no one would see him.
He escaped some of the ridicule.
And time after time he
couldn't get it going
he had to push it back.
But it never dawned on
him that he would not
ultimately realize his dream.
When this magnificent
machine completed its first
long journey with Benz at the wheel
every beat of the engine
found an answering echo
in the heart of the driver
as every turn of the
wheels brought him closer
to his goal.
To the realization of what once
was a fantasy.
Now in order for you to turn
your fantasies into a fact
you have to go through
exactly the same process
as Carl Benz.
And if you do go through the same process
you'll meet with exactly the same success
regardless of the opposition
you might come up against.
You have to ask, am I able to turn this
fantasy of mine into a fact?
Can I actually realize it?
Can I turn my dreams into reality?
Now you're either going
to say, yes I'm able to.
Or, no I'm not.
If you realize you are able, if you have
an understanding of this potential,
this power within you then
you have to ask yourself,
are you willing?
And there's a long series of tests there
you don't even know what you're
going to come up against.
One thing is for certain
you'll come up against ridicule.
You may have to move
you may have to do all kinds of things
that you don't even think about.
You have to be willing to
do whatever is required
if you really want to turn
your fantasy into a fact.
The second you say, yes I'm willing
at that instant you've
created your theory.
- Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this video because Will (mumbling)
So if there's a person you
want me to profile next
check out the link in the description
you can go and cast your vote.
I also would love to know
which clips resonated most
with you, what lesson you're
going to take from this video
and immediately apply to your
life or to business somehow.
Leave it in the comments
below I'm really curious to
find out what you have to say.
I was going to give a quick
shout out to Tuan Nguyen
thank you so much ready
for picking up 10 copies
of my book, share it with your friends
and posting that awesome review on Amazon.
I really appreciate
the support, I'm really
glad you enjoyed my book.
Thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(airplane flying)
(basketball bounce)
- Your present or past results have
absolutely nothing to do
with what's going to happen
from this point forward.
Now that was the point that Ray Stanford
drilled into my head.
You see I kept thinking,
well gee I such a mess up
you know I've done
everything wrong up 'til now.
I'm 26, I'm broke, I'm not happy.
Everything was wrong.
He said, "Bob that's all in the past.
He said, "Every moment is a new moment.
"We shouldn't condemn ourselves.
And he said, "What you were
yesterday you paid for.
"What you are today you decide what."
That's exactly what Troy would say.
This power in no way is
limited by precedent.
Even in a creative
state we sometimes don't
understand that.
You know why airplanes right up to today
almost have wings on them?
Because birds have wings.
Birds fly.
They have wings.
If you're going to get a plane to fly
you've got to put wings on it.
Do you, no, we've got planes
flying without wings today.
You know why, never didn't need wings.
But you see the thinking
was to a degree limited
by precedent.
Birds fly with wings
planes have to have wings.
Planes do not have to have wings.
You're creative if you can
visualize it you can do it.
It doesn't matter what it
is, that's what Hill said
anything the mind can
conceive and believe it
you can achieve.
You see the beautiful part
about goals and understanding it
is goals are not to get.
Goals is not you don't
set goals for acquisition.
You set goals to grow.
You set goals to reach inside and stretch
and go where you've never been.
You set goals to take into a place
you've never gone before.
And you grow as your human
being and you know something
you never go back.
Choice is one of the
most important concepts
that you can get.
We're going to be talking about
the laws of the universe.
One of the laws is a law clarity.
There'd be note inside
to the room you're in
if there was an outside.
You couldn't have a right side your body
without a left or a top or a bottom.
Or a front without a back.
You can't have a bad without a good.
See the truth is we make it bad or good.
Ralph Waldo Trin
In Tune With The Infinite, a great book.
He said, "Nothing is
good or bad except our
"will make it so."
Well if everything is both good and bad
and we bring it together what's right
in the center?
If everything here is bad
everything here is good,
what's in the center?
Just is.
Everything just is.
You choose whether you're going to look at
the downside or the upside.
Michael Beckwith gave
me a marvelous concept,
he said, "It doesn't matter
what happens in your life
"doesn't matter what happens
you can't control the
"circumstance but you
can certainly control
"how you deal with them."
He said, "When anything happens
"step number one it is
what it is accept it.
"It's either going to control you
"or you're going to control it."
That's a choice.
Step number two, "Harvest the good."
Isn't that a neat word, harvest?
Harvest the good.
There's good and bad in everything
just harvest the good.
Step number three, "Forgive all the rest."
Forgive means like go up completely.
It's a choice.
Yet if you let go of the bad
the good seems to grow.
You and I have a choice.
It may be a difficult choice
sometimes if you're
dealing with a particular
difficult individual
or a particularly difficult circumstance.
Nevertheless we've got the
power within us to do it.
So as you go through the
day doesn't matter what
anybody says doesn't matter what happens
you have a choice to say,
"That's good."
W Clement Stone became the wealthiest man
in the United States of America by 1970
because he always said,
"That's good."
Doesn't matter what it was
he'd say, "That's good."
And then he'd look for the good.
That's a good choice for you to make
and make it all day long.
So your word for the day
is choice, choice, choice.
And only you have the ability to do that.
And if you choose right
you are going to get results that stick.